let's return to the rail strike story
now because there's widespread
disruption across the country with more
than 40 000 workers striking over pay
and conditions it's the second walkout
in three days and the sixth of the
summer with unions and the government
reportedly still some distance apart in
agreeing a settlement well joining me
live from london houston is the general
secretary of the rmt union mick lynch
thank you very much for joining us this
morning mr lynch could you just update
us on exactly where the negotiations are
at the moment please
well we'll be engaging with the
companies again next week starting on
monday both network rail and the train
operators
but what we've seen uh in the last
couple of days is a wave of hostility
emanating from grant shaps he's
threatened
uh yesterday to sack all these workers
behind me and workers across the country
by issuing statutory redundancy letters
he has also shown that he's completely
incompetent in regards to the railway he
doesn't know how it works
and he's making wild threats about
banning strikes and making trade unions
virtually illegal so he's escalating the
dispute
when where he should be is trying to
create an atmosphere of good will and
positivity so that we can work towards a
solution but at the root of it is his
is his decision to cut four billion
pounds both from
uh london underground at two billion and
the main line at two billion that's
caused the funding crisis in our
industry
and he's wanting our members to pay to
pay the price of that in terms of
maybe five or six thousand job cuts
a pay freeze that's gone on for two or
three years
uh ripping up our conditions issuing new
contracts of employment
and so therefore what he's now indulging
in is fire and re-hire
which he's taken the trouble to condemn
all through the summer he seems to
forgot forgotten that
he's also forgotten that about six or
eight weeks ago he said that he's going
to ban overtime on the railway and some
people have stopped working overtime and
therefore the railway's ground to a halt
in some areas so
it's a ridiculous and contradictory
situation where he wants to get rid of
thousands of workers
and at the same time demand that they
work overtime but on other occasions
demand that they don't
so he's got to get out of the way or
create an atmosphere of goodwill so that
i can negotiate along with my officials
a settlement to this to this uh
crisis and the the problems we've got
and get the railways back to running on
behalf of the people so that we can run
the system properly
and our passengers can benefit from the
services and the economy can benefit and
so can our environment
now a large part of this dispute focuses
on pay and the government say that the
pay offer that they've put forward would
they think be accepted by your members
but you don't want to put that pay deal
to your members why is that
well it shows how out of touch the
government are they've they've made a
payoff of a half the people in this
dispute the train operating companies
have made no offer
on pay and yesterday he said he was
going to make them all redundant
there is an offer on the table from
network rail which is fifty percent of
our members it's a three-year
pay deal at eight percent and and that
would have to cover next year as well as
this year and last year
inflation this week on the retail price
price index was 12.3
so if we accepted that pay offer we
would be getting about a quarter of next
year's inflation which is likely to be
15 or 16 percent so our members aren't
prepared to accept that but before we
even get on to pay we have to sort out
job security which we haven't done and
we have to work through the
modernization agenda that the companies
want and the changes the terms and
conditions and what they've essentially
said
across the railway is they want to rip
up our contracts make assign new
contracts and if we don't want to take
those
members are going to be put out work so
that's not an atmosphere when you make
an agreement i had a meeting on
wednesday night with 14 000 rmt members
attending it online and nobody put
forward the idea that we should accept
what's on the table we don't need a
referendum you can see on the streets of
london london and around the country
today a massive turnout on our picket
lines all of our members are rallying to
the call that this strike will go on
until we get a settlement we don't need
a referendum would be
could you explain to us what would be a
fair deal in your eyes
yes the basis of a fair deal is getting
a job security agreement so we don't get
thousands of people made redundant we
move on from there to work out the
conditions of service and the
modernization agenda we have to get
guarantees about the pension scheme
which they want to rip up they want to
dilute our benefits in retirement and
increase the contributions and then when
we've done that we can move on to a pay
package that has to address the cost of
living crisis
and the fact that we've not had a pay
rise for the last two or three years so
it's a package deal that we're trying to
negotiate and when we've addressed
all the subjects didn't that not just
pay which grant sap seems to be obsessed
with
seems to have forgotten the threats he's
made to our people
we can get to a solution that will be a
package deal that covers all the aspects
in the dispute
and i wanted to ask you looking at a
website read.com it says the average
train driver salary in the uk is 48 and
a half thousand pounds a year what do
you say to people who say
that the salaries are already high
enough and pay pay shouldn't be an issue
at this time when everybody is
struggling
well standing behind me now you can
there's not a train driver on this
picket line there are catering workers
there are train managers
there are station workers and all sorts
of people that are going to run the
railway their salaries are typically
about 25 to 30 000 pounds
a year they work around the clock
uh 363 days a year
running our railway in all weathers and
all times of the day at night they have
not had a pay rise for two or three
years most of them there are nothing
like 45 000 or any other figures that
grant chaps and new journalists quote
night and day they're on very modest pay
and they need a pay rise but of course
they won't get a pay rise unless they've
got a job so what we've got to do first
is secure their jobs and then move on to
the other aspects in the dispute which
is cutting up their terms and conditions
and a fire and rehire stance that's now
coming from the government when we've
solved that we can move on to the pay
but the pay is a long way from being
on the table now because we've got to
sort out all the other issues and if i
told my people behind me the figures
that you're quoting they would either
laugh or cry at what you're saying
because it's a complete distortion of
what railway workers have to put up with
and what they get paid
well we've got you i just wanted to ask
you about some comments you've made
about the ukraine situation and russia's
invasion i read that you said that the
eu has provoked trouble in ukraine and
it's wrong to purely blame russia for
the invasion do you stand by those
comments why do you believe that
i don't believe that and it's that's a
partial uh quote from a very long
conversation what i believe is it is no
justification for russia's
invasion of the ukraine there is nothing
that
that could warrant such an aggressive
and murderous act
the ukrainian people have the right to
live in the sovereign nation under their
own constitution making their own laws
in a democratic process
and what the russians need to do now is
cease their aggression
cease fire and withdraw
from all areas of the uh ukrainian
sovereign territory immediately and if
they do that
uh there can be some peace in that
region that what you've said is the
distortion of my beliefs russia has no
right to be in the ukraine and they
should get out straight away
did you say that the eu has provoked
trouble in ukraine
what i said was that there was a
quite a long run-up to this this this
issue but what i've also said on the
record numerous times
in public statements and written
statements that russia is completely
unjustified and their war of aggression
on the ukrainian people is an outrage
and it's probably illegal
and the leaders of the russian regime
including putin should be called to
account for
it lynch general secretary of the rmt
union thank you very much for joining us
this morning on sky news